One thing that I'd been doing in my tour
repeatedly when I talk about the first
chapter of my book,
which is stand up straight with your
shoulders back,
it's a discussion of hierarchies and
their eternal nature,
right?
Because my claim is,
and it's not my claim,
I think it's mirror fact that organisms
that have to cooperate and compete with
other organisms have their type
inevitably arranged themselves into
hierarchies and that's been going on for
so long,
which,
uh,
which is at least 300 million years that
our nervous systems have adapted to
hierarchies as if they're a permanent
element of being right,
more permanent than trees,
like seriously permanent at the most
fundamental neurochemical,
the one that regulates the entire brain.
Serotonin is acutely sensitive to
hierarchical distinctions.
And so that's part of the proposition.
So the reason I laid that proposition
forward was to say whatever pitfalls
hierarchies might produce,
you cannot lay them at the feet of the
West Patriarchy or capitalism.
It's like that's a nonstarter.
You're wrong and not just a little bit
wrong.
You're so seriously wrong that if you
insist upon doing that,
you won't even achieve your own aims
because you're actually not grappling
with the problem.
The problem is if hierarchies are a
problem,
which they are,
the problem is way more serious than
mere capitalist.
It's way deeper and if you're actually
interested in rectifying the constantly
the negative consequences of
hierarchies,
then you're going to have to get a lot
more sophisticated than their,
than your idiot Marxism.
So,
so,
so part of the elaboration of that
argument is,
well,
hierarchies are inevitable because we
have to solve complex problems and we
have to solve them socially.
And when you implement a solution to a
complex problem,
socially you produce a hierarchy because
some people are better at the
implementation than others.
So there's a hierarchy of competence and
then there's a hierarchy of distribution
of the spoils.
And so,
and in both of those hierarchies,
you get a disproportionate clumping of
resources at the top and dispossession
at the bottle and the nature of
hierarchies.
So what's the left for?
The left is to remind those who are
benefiting from the hierarchies that the
hierarchy comes at a cost and the cost
is the clumping of people at the bottom
and that that's an eternal cost and it's
not trivial,
and so that's what the left should be
properly focused on.
The left should be providing the voice
of those who are dispossessed by
hierarchies and the right should be
saying,
yeah,
but the damn hierarchies are necessary
and they're not only necessary,
but there are also productive than the
left says yes,
but they tilt towards tyranny and they
can be occupied inappropriately by
people who are playing games of power.
Fair enough to write has to take that
into account.
The hierarchy can rigidity,
rigidity,
and is likely to do that.
And it can be taken over by people who
are corrupt and that's likely to happen.
And so,
but,
but it's okay because the dialogue could
work out the right can say,
well yeah,
we need the damn hierarchies and they
need to be buttressed and the left can
say yes,
but they have to be maintained property
so they don't deteriorate and
degenerate.
And,
and I think that's,
I think that's ancient wisdom.
I think the ancient Egyptians had
figured that out in their symbolic
representations.
So now when the left goes too far,
it does something like say,
well,
how about no hierarchy?
It's like,
no,
how about not wrong?
Because all that happens if you fly.
One of the things that happens if you
flatten out the hierarchy is that you
can't even organize your perceptions.
You can't perceive the world without
looking at the world through a hierarchy
of value.
And if because you can't perceive the
world unless you make one thing more
important than all the other things
because you don't even know what to look
at,
and if one thing isn't more important
than all the other things,
then you have nothing to aim at.
If you have nothing to aim at,
then you have no meaning in your life.
So the left can't just demolish the
hierarchies in the name of some equality
of outcome,
let's say,
because you blow out the future,
you leave people aimless,
and you destroyed the very institutions
that allow people to make competent
progress in the world.
That's not an acceptable outcome,
so we have to,
we have to agree to live with the
tension necessity for hierarchies that
proclivity for them to pathologize and
the necessary voice of the left and
speaking for the.
For the dispossessed.